قالت السلطات المصريه ان ثلاثه مواطنين
بريطانيين فقدوا بعد ان اشتعلت النيران في
قارب غطس لهم كانوا على متن قبالات الساحل
على البحر الاحمر كما قالت محافظه البحر
الاحمر ان اثني عشر من افراد الطاقم واثني
عشر سائحا بريطانيا تم انقاذه عندما
اشتعلت النيران في المركب قباله مدينه
مرسى علم جنوب البحر الاحمر وقالت عقب
الفحص الاولي للسفينه ان ماسه كهربائيا في
غرفه محرك القارب ادى الى اندلاع النيران
واكدت ان عمليات البحث عن السائحين
البريطانيين الثلاثه ما زالت
جاريه
معي من الغردقه لمزيد من المتابعه مراسله
العربيه ندى حجازي ندى اهلا وسهلا بك هل
توضحت ملابسات هذا الحريق وما هو مصير
السائحين البريطانيين الثلاثه هل عرف
اهلا بك يعني لازال لسه ما فيش صوره واضحه
يعني
لمكان السائحين المفقودين هو المرجح او
يعني المتوقع ان هم يكونوا لسه في السفينه
الغارقه هي طبعا ابتعدت عن مكان الحريق 20
كيلومتر ولا زال البحث عنهم مستمر في
السفينه الغارقه
والناجين يعني دلوقتي موجودين في مرسى
السياحي
لتلقي الراحه
والعلاج اللازم بس هم يعني كويسين وطبعا
الفحص المبدئي للمركب بيقول انه كان بسبب
ماسك كهربائي في غرفه المحركات طيب ندى
اكثر من حادثه في الايام الاخيره بالقرب
من السواحل المصريه يعني حادثه القرش الذي
هاجمت سائحا روسيا
وقضى نحبه الان حادث
اشتعال هذا المركب وثلاث سائحين مفقودين
بالطبع لا يمكن الربط بين هذين الحادثتين
او بين هذه الحوادث ولكن تاثير ذلك على
قطاع السياحه على المشهد السياحي في مصر
ونحن نعرف ان قطاع السياحه في مصر يضر
جزءا لا يساهم به على الخزينه المصريه
اكيد طبعا بس يعني النهارده انا في وجودي
في الغردقه
الشواطئ بدات تفتح نوعا ماابس طبعا في
تحذير ان احنا في حد معين ما ينفعش حد
يعديه في السباحه انا شايفه ان الاقبال
والله لا يعني كبير او معقول في العادي في
الطبيعي طبعا ده مش وقت الزروه في السياحه
في البحر الاحمر في مصر يعني
مش مش وقت زوره لكن ده المعدل الطبيعي
عادي جدا الدنيا كويسه مفيش خوف او هلع
اكبر من اللازم لانه ده حدث عربي نادر مش
بيحصل في مصر كتير اما بالنسبه للحريق
فبرده هي يعني مش مش حاجه
بتتكرر يعني ده مقصرش قوي على رحلات اللي
طالعه ولكن اكيد في نفس الوقت هو في في
حاله من من الزعر من من الموقف نفسه من ان
في ثلاث اشخاص احنا دلوقتي مش عارفين هم
فين طيب هل زادت السلطات المصريه من
اجراءات السلامه بعد هذه الحوادث يعني
خلال متابعتك شفتي انه لا في اجراءات اكثر
يعني تشدد على مستوى السلامه العامه على
الشواطئ ام لا يعني الامور ما زالت على
حالها ندى
لا في اجراءات كتير جدا للحفاظ على سلامه
كل السياح وكل زائري مدن البحر الاحمر
خصوصا بعد حادثه القرش كمان وفي كمان
اجراءات
ومحاولات للبحث فان الفنادق تحط شباك في
في البحار المفتوحه علشان كمان الاسماك دي
ما تقدرش ان هي تقرب من الناس اللي بتسبح
لحد معين وعلشان ما يتكررش طبعا حادث زي
ده مع طبعا ان في طول الوقت ناس على
الشواطئ بتحذر وبتتابع
الوقت متابعه كل حد بينزل وبيتنوه لو حد
راح ابعد لحد ما الاجراء بهذا القدر من
الغردقه مراسله العربي ندى حجازي شكرا
جزيلا لكن نادى على هذه المتابعه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات